Christmas is great and all I guess but
you know what it's the beginning of
Kamala Harris's favorite holiday
Kwanzaa
they call it the world's oldest Quan she
never celebrated this of course not
world's oldest Kwanzaa parade it's a
Kwanzaa forever that's not I don't think
that's right
um okay don't make fun of this I dare
you it's a kickoff to the Seven Day
celebrate uh the the hold on hold on the
traditional
Thomas the Tank Engine Kwanza float of
course that we have every year that
we've had since the beginning of Kwanzaa
the what look at the look at the screen
the traditional tomics the Tank Engine
Kwanza float is
Thomas the Dank engine yeah so all this
time Thomas was black well I mean I
don't ask those kind of things
by the way and if that trains her you
know the manatee kids there and it
includes some classic cars as well as
some tricked out ones too it's fun for
the whole family tricked out hold on I
know of course she did but what does
classic cars have to do with a Kwanzaa
parade in South La
definitely and features music okay you
know I feel like I should probably have
this Royce uh I mean wait we are just
yeah we're on the we're just not around
we'll do whatever we want we don't
remember the hell we want to see you so
I don't want to even spoil it okay but
if you're gonna do the Thomas the Tank
Engine I need the theme song and if
you're gonna I feel like you should play
the theme song I can't believe you're
gonna do this to me what okay no I'll do
it I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
because I'll do it but you're a piece
you're a Merry Christmas you're a piece
of [ __ ] happy Quantum we're on the front
page
[Music]
hey this is not the one no oh damn it I
know which one you were looking for
though that's why I said that
I was looking for the n-word I know I
know well [ __ ] you you hey you've ruined
everything hey hey Marsh good news keep
watching the video
cars as well as some tricked out ones
too it's fun for the whole family and
features musical performances as well
the event started at the corner of oh
yeah actually you know what Marsh I
don't have that one but I do have one of
the musical performances
um I think
I can't do what you want but I think I
could do something close I do have a
musical performance give me a second
here hold done
and with the cars you're about to see
this really works
man why do they have to ruin things man
why is even good like these things are
just memory hold and there were so many
funny things that were made back in the
day I know man I know you're not allowed
to be funny anymore you know that it was
so many funny things just are gone
uh are they single I don't know no why
are they why are they all in cages why
are they all in cages I don't know
either that's a really good quote hold
on a second are they single hold on a
second
Frozen brought up a really good point
why are they in cages What's Happening
Here
Society Man Okay can somebody read to me
what Kwanzaa actually is because I'm not
gonna lie to you I don't know what
Kwanza is and at this point I'm afraid
to ask
no no no no is it gonna
all right is it gonna actually explain
Kwanzaa or is it a joke video
I don't like that he didn't answer
yes at the corner of Adams and Crenshaw
boulevards so okay just to be clear I'm
gonna paint the picture on Adams and
Crenshaw Boulevard which we all know
where that is it's in [ __ ] rap songs
they have black people in cages and this
is a positive Kwanzaa tradition
okay no I'm being serious this is what
this that's what's happening I'm not
making a joke I'm just observing what
I'm seeing
so apparently Kwanzaa is it's not
religious it just celebrates
African-American cultural that's
actually pretty good okay here it is we
have it meaning a Kwanzaa by cooliobot
[Music]
cool I hope you're ready to celebrate oh
are you here with my friends
if only someone it's Kwanza here it is
and I'm gonna tell y'all how we
celebrate Kwanzaa Zoidberg dab time how
about I just lie down
[Music]
the seven basic principles that go to
make them Kwanzaa so set your ass down
and have some knowledge
[Music]
Cooperative economics your Boondocks I'm
talking here put away the comics so Uber
is another one that stands for
creativity like the ever-changing nature
of my sexual proclivity
but I don't speak Swahili something
about a pine tree and they're all
wrestling dealing so even
black people make fun of Kwanzaa not
knowing what it is I just want to be
because that's what's happening right
that's that was Coolio R.I.P well he's
not a real black guy he's probably a
bunch of Jewish people wrote that well
yeah I mean it was [ __ ] Mac raining
screw so yeah probably I'm sure Coolio
was just grateful to be there yeah he's
dead now
hey but you know what what about the
traditional Kwanzaa slide
[Music]
yes
[Music]
that's a clip of Kwanzaa slide a fun
give me the full song is it fun I'm on
it yeah it looks fun hey guys hey hey
black guys whenever you make line
dancing songs why they all invite
sliding an educational song by
grammy-nominated Family musicians called
but not winning right
culture Queen and fuge it's also timely
since today is the first day of Kwanzaa
and this morning someone Homer won a
Grammy in the episode he threw it over a
balcony goes oh oh it's a Grammy and
they threw it back to him
hold on Show links okay hold on
uh let's see here
yeah before I don't need the news report
what I need I need the actual video
directly in my veins
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God this re you know what this
feels like I'll tell you right now and
you guys are going to say I'm 100 right
not even this seems like well yes but
this seems like this seems like a
beginning of a UPN show like the intro
of a UPN show doesn't it oh God Jesus
[ __ ] you're dead on oh my God like Mo
like it would be a show that got one
season that came on after Moesha I was
gonna say
it looks like an In Living Color parody
of the opening of a WB show
yeah UPN show it's the same thing oh
it's the same thing yeah
[Music]
starring Queen Latifah yes exactly
Marlon Wayans Brandy
who who is who is the dad in Friday
John Withers John Witherspoon John
Witherspoon has the dad on that show of
course let's go
okay guys you're explaining to me
us how to do the dance but no one can
seem to explain to me what the [ __ ]
Kwanzaa is
because this song is giving me no
information on Kwanzaa but giving me a
lot of information on how to do a
modified Electric Slide
yeah well that's the first step to
learning Kwanzaa
apparently hold on we oh no more people
I mean honestly this is kind of what I
was I'm learning about Quantum there's
so much a bunch of black people wearing
Marcus Garvey colors and dancing around
all right so business as usual okay
you're right I'm not gonna argue that
and honestly I don't know enough about
Kwan to argue with you so sure yeah I
mean it's fine okay we should start
supporting Kwanzaa because every time I
hear about Kwanzaa it's always these
sort of like churchy non-threatening
like yeah different world blacks which
I mean
that's part of the problem [ __ ]
dressed like Sinbad yeah
I mean that black guy in the [ __ ]
leather [ __ ] uh uh Sheamus from WWE
The Irish hat uh that guy seems like
he'd be a cool black guy named honestly
you'd be like hey what's up Derek hey
man yo I brought your packages up to
your door man they were getting rained
on you're like okay thanks man
appreciate it and you know what he he's
probably the guy he's playing poker
Thursday and you're like you know yeah
let me know what time he's the guy when
you walk outside and say what's up he's
like he wanna he gives you the rest of
his joint you want to finish this I'm
high and he just gives it to you like
hey thanks man that's real nice to you
yeah and then he [ __ ] about his job
as the Mater D it's some [ __ ]
restaurant before he goes back upstairs
that got me working every [ __ ]
day at Kwanzaa his favorite anyway man
be good bro
his favorite black movie character is
Mayor Goldie Wilson from Back to the
Future his favorite non-anime movie
character fair enough okay you know what
Fair all right
hmm
something's new day fans
[Laughter]
oh God he looks like Kofi Kingston fan
club I love this where are all the news
like those are the ones I want to deal
with well one of them has a broken spine
and the other one kind of hurt himself
I'm sorry I apologize I met the ones
with that Vibe and the Kwanzaa slide
people where are these people what I
keep seeing the ones that are punching
people and ripping kiosks apart at the
Spirit Airlines terminal yeah I mean I'm
just murdering white babies where's the
[ __ ]
where are these black people because
I'll listen I'll Coast on Kwanzaa if
this if we'll get more of this if you
know what I actually do agree with you
yeah this is fine I'll support your
cultural thing all right that's fine he
just behaves yeah
hey how you doing Daquan man they've
been riding my ass at Chipotle my power
level's like 90. dog dog they pushing it
anyway man I gotta get some sleep anyway
you want to come over hey you want to
come over the new season of one punch
man just came out I've been I've been on
that PS5 waiting list for like at least
six months these are the black guys that
have every special edition of Kingdom
Hearts that's ever come out
[Laughter]
this guy has a Soul Calibur fight stick
s
they go together they're [ __ ] Honda
Civic and they've got the [ __ ]
keyblade on their [ __ ] keychain of
course yeah no he's got a key he's got a
keyblade dab tool
[Laughter]
played dab tool and he's got a [ __ ]
half Filipino half Mexican like 11 of a
girlfriend yeah you know but she's a bum
like she's a college student bomb but
she's a [ __ ] 11 yeah I'll explain it
he's a black guy with a bong yeah yes
this girl next to his no plural you're
right his 11 Filipino mixed girlfriend
always sits behind him cross leg while
he's playing online on Xbox
honey you want me to get you a Bang from
the fridge
bro she making these banging ass spring
rolls dog
I'm all for Kwanzaa I think we just sold
everybody on Kwanzaa guys
if it's gonna be half Filipino half
black chicks hanging out with [ __ ]
harmless anime black dudes we're in as
Patrice used to call them magical [ __ ]
exactly he's like you know type of Dude
to be wearing shiny jeans and [ __ ] yes
hey yo dog want to come over for Kwanzaa
Cedric's gonna make kiyosa I'm gonna
hang my my scale replica Cloud sword for
Final Fantasy and then we're gonna we're
gonna play some Persona five honey honey
where are the condoms they're next to my
third row of funko pop dolls just grab
them they're down there okay
yeah this guy this guy liked Suicide
Squad more than black panther oh this
guy didn't buy on a hype about Black
Panther holy he's one of those it's like
nah man that's funny for that race
[ __ ] that's funny that was not a
great it was a good movie it was a
height but he he pre-ordered Eric July's
comic book
when you go to his house and he offers
you water he offers you still sparkling
a ramune okay look this guy this guy
doesn't actually subscribe to Young Ripa
but he shows up in his algorithm
he looks like he has a minimum of two
boxes of Pocky sticks in his glove
compartment
every Japanese Kit Kat
okay look he has little tiny Mochi ice
creams in his uh freezer he he's the
only guy that rolls up to the [ __ ]
party with boba tea
he uses the word Neko daily okay we're
done now okay
he has his own Pokemon Cipher okay look
enough all right we're done kwanza's
over now guys okay he eats KFC during
Christmas ah I was proud of that that's
[ __ ] up that was very funny you know
it was [ __ ] hilarious we were banging
those out